creators a lot of times do a couple
things wrong one they'd rather just get
a manager or something to represent them
and because they don't want to do
business development which I understand
some people are just naturally creative
and not business oriented I think for
all of you a lot of this is about taking
things into your own hands number two
they don't integrate Brands into their
content day to day enough put Brands
into your content for free and then
watch how many Brands including those
Brands start coming to you so many
creators think that they're not going to
put a brand in because they're not going
to give away for free what they do when
in reality it's the reverse you could DM
every brand in the world and say not
well you do work with me you could just
say I like your product keep up the good
work you could say hi to the 50 brands
that you think are the coolest just
literally I'm a fan of your product and
two of them are going to reach out to
you if nothing else get some free
samples of your handbags you like you
know so